[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à dans le grand studio
du figaro on est en direct c'est figaro
live et on attend vos points de vue en
particulier sur la dernière idée en
vogue du conseil scientifique l'auto
confinement alors c'est l'idée pour être
en forme justement pour aller voir selon
la formule consacrée papy et mamie on en
débat ce soir avec béatrice giblin
bonsoir béatrice rédactrice en chef de
la revue hérodote
profitez-en parce que c'est encore le
moment d'aller se procurer le dernier
numéro sur l'afrique médiane le prochain
il y apparaît en janvier et ce sera
consacrée au maghreb
on a hâte de le lire avec vous alexis
braisé bonsoir l'extension vincent
directeur des rédactions du groupe
figaro en une du figaro ce demain demain
on te voit tourner autour de l'idée de
brillantes évidemment de référendum de
maniema kron dont nous allons parler
tout à l'heure en deuxième partie
exactement vous avez vu le sommaire donc
j'ai plus rien à vous dire sauf à vous
annoncer que demain également dans le
prix vous aurez les résultats de la
réponse à la question êtes vous
favorables au référendum proposé par
emmanuel macron pour inscrire la défense
de l'environnement dans la constitution
vous êtes déjà nombreux à voter et bien
vous pouvez continuer à voter même si
pour l'instant c'est le nom qui
l'emportent
risque-t-on d'abord d'être sanctionnés
si on rate les cours jeudi et vendredi
c'est avec la démission de michel rubio
las cet après-midi le papier le plus lu
sur le site du figaro et si on pose la
question bien c'est après avoir pris la
connaissance d'une recommandation du
conseil scientifique approuvée par jean
castex en personne quelques conseils
scientifiques dit quelque chose je passe
de très raisonnable il dit d'abord si
vous le pouvez d'ailleurs c'est ce qui
se pratique dans certains pays étrangers
dont beaucoup auto confiné vous huit
jours avant noël si vous pouvez ce n'est
pas possible vous habiller cette
recommandation bien entendu pourtant à
chaque fois que cela est possible
surtout si on doit recevoir à noël des
personnes vulnérables
le conseil scientifique je vous dire
qu'on l'appuie a même dit si vous pouvez
ne pas amener vos enfants l'école jeu
et vendredi c'est la période de huit
jours pour le faire
alors à linverse y en a un qui n'est pas
trop convaincu c'est le président ait
l'air de la région paca est lui-même
médecin
renaud muselier pour le conseil
scientifique j'aimais les plus grandes
réserves en permanence sur leurs propos
et je trouve qu'ils s'expriment beaucoup
trop il ya une addition il ya une
addition de directives de d'ordre ou de
semis ordre qui d'accord qui fabrique
quelque part toujours une addition de
choses qui finissent par lasser
le cnta confort ne pas comprendre
ayrault
alors patrice qu'est-ce que vous faisait
dans écoutiez renault vise à lier oui je
trouve beau dit il fut médecin je pense
il fut urgentiste il ya sans doute bien
longtemps ça a quand même été un
partisan de didier raoul tu bon il a
pris des positions au début en mars que
je trouve qu'un responsable politique de
son importance il est quand même
président d'une très grande région ne
doit ne doivent apprendre voilà je passe
les partisans de dirhams et il a dit que
sa mère il a au début excusez moi non
non j'ai une mémoire qui n'est pas
encore trop faible au début il a très
clairement soutenu clara houle
accompagnée d'estrosi bon chacun sait
que mes geôliers a fait des études de
médecine et ce qui n'est pas le cas des
sosies donc voilà mais nous je suis je
suis je trouve pas ça sérieux qu'après
une caresse président de région d'une
grande région elle serait petit que ce
serait pareil d'ailleurs puisse dire bah
moi ce que dit le conseil scientifique
au 1 toute façon ils disent tout et son
contraire sans vouloir voir qu'on est
sur une situation très particulière
compliqué avec un virus qu'on
connaissait pas bon on n'a jamais trouvé
formidable ce qui se passait aux
pays-bas bon ben voilà il décide un
confinement de cinq semaines aujourd'hui
on a trouvé que c'était très bien ce qui
se passait en allemagne va en allemagne
aujourd'hui sont confrontés
effectivement une reprise de l'épidémie
et prennent des mesures qu'ils sont très
très strict
voilà c'est ça veut dire que je jette la
pierre à personne
ça veut dire que c'est compliqué que
c'est difficile et que si on veut
préserver des fêtes de noël par on sait
qu'il ya à peu près huit jours où on
peut avoir une incubation
voilà c'est cesser tout fait je trouve
ça pas sérieux un lip si vous trouvez
que c'est pas sérieux est ce que l'on
pense et moi je pense c'est un débat
qu'on a le droit de mener je pense que
que muselier peut-être parce qu'il est
médecin est d'autant plus fondée à
pouvoir critiquer d'autres médecins non
c'est pas parole d'évangile se dit que
c'est ce que dit le haut conseil de
santé j'ai jamais dit que c'était
reconnaître quand même qu'ils ont fait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'erreurs ils
se sont plantés sur les masses qui se
sont plantés sur les tests sont plantés
sur tracé sur isolé et ses bons donc
critiquer ce haut conseil
ça me paraît pas en tout cas un crime de
lèse majesté
après coup discuter et quant à dire que
la france s'en tire particulièrement
bien je crois qu'on en ait vraiment pas
dire ça
je note qu'il ya quatre fois moins de
morts en allemagne il ya deux fois mois
de délai de croissance en comparable
je dis simplement que quand on pensait
que tout allait toujours très bien
qu'ils avaient toujours la bonne
attitude ils ont été surpris on a dit
regarde par une reprise d'une épidémie
qu'il pensait parfaitement contrôlée bon
voilà les allemands que je suis
aujourd'hui vous faites le nombre de
morts par million d'années
la france est en 16e position
les pires c'est les belges il en 1572
par millions
la france on est seize les américains
sont très longs et toujours canal c'est
une catastrophe aux etats unis ils sont
pas si loin que nous on fore la
française états unis on est quand même
dans un mouchoir
les allemands ils sont même pas dans le
classement ils sont au delà du 50e
donc voyez bien qu'on nous dise que les
allemands sont à mon sens à ce mal la
seule chose que j'ai dit c'est que cette
épidémie et la façon dont se comporte ce
virus surprend et qu'on est surpris aux
pays bas voilà c'est tout je ne dis rien
d'autre que ça et je reviens sur
muselier qui avait pris des positions
excusez moi je peux ne pas être d'accord
avec vous là dessus a pris des positions
de l'autre mais bien sûr sur paca en
attaque armée en effet ctive mans mais
non c'était pas grand chose et que tout
ça pouvait se régler avec un traitement
qu'on l'avait d'un paca et que tout
irait très bien madame la marquise il
l'a quand même
y est je trouve que pour un responsable
politique on doit être continue à lui
d'y avoir des médecins y compris les
rangs des hôpitaux parisiens et des
patrons de service ça qui continue de
dire que eux leur leur maladie les
autres étaient des dialyses on sait que
le rognon vous n'avez plus personne
qu'il est je vous promets qu'il y en a
qui continuent de le dire barghouti le
disent pas publiquement parce que mes
mais il y en a quand même qui continuent
de le dire pour enfin bon on va lensois
sur le sujet qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est à dire six lotos
confinement oui le temps que vous avez
vous auto consultés n'ont évidemment pas
eu ya comme un moment c'est quand même
curieux de choisir le jour du décompte
il ment pour nous demander deux auteurs
confiné alors moi je je comprends que je
conçois convié des incertitudes qu'on
sache pas que ça compliqué mais comme un
principe qui campe principe de non
contradiction on veut pas le jour du
déconfinement demander aux gens de se re
confiné je ne comprends pas pourquoi le
jour où monsieur castex vient nous
vendre les vaccins il fait venir un
spécialiste des vaccins à côté de lui
qui explique qu' on sait pas trop ce
qu'il faut commencer et que les vaccins
fait des douze jours mais c'est quand
même invraisemblable et hier encore
edouard philippe fait une grande
campagne de tests au havre et vient dire
nous allons faire des tests massif c'est
quelque chose de nouveau d'intéressante
et à côté il y avait rock et du fouet
aux folles et est aussi faut quand même
se méfier au moins les tests je demande
à voir
mais est-ce qu'on pourrait pas avoir un
message univoque en tout cas de coques
des responsables publics par un moment
donné qui disent pas blanc et noir à la
fois et confinement déconfinement auto
confinement le même jour c'est bizarre
sur ça et est ce que vous allez vous
auto confiné tout dépend ce qu'on entend
par auto confiné moi je sais que je ne
serai pas noël avec douze personnes
autour de ma table
je sais que j'ai limité le nombre de
gens avec qui je serai oussera c'est ton
sera pas six voilà parce que la table va
permettre que ce soit ça on a ra oui je
ne fais pas noël comme je le fais tous
les ans avec toute ma famille c'est
c'est une évidence bon est ce que je
ce seraient pas vaccinés les autres ne
seront pas non plus on va donc être
prudent et des personnes âgées
voilà là dessus je le ferai bon ça ne
veut pas dire pour autant que je vais
totalement me confiner à pas sortir tout
dépend ce qu'on met dans le confinement
si vous voudrez voilà donc en auto
confinement je pense que quand on le dit
comme ça ces deux débats et éviter le
plus possible peut-être moi je
l'interprète comme ça éviter le plus
possible d'aller vous balader là dans
les centres commerciaux ou autre faites
attention si vous voulez recevoir des
gens chez vous faites attention moi je
ferai attention voilà le tout c'est du
bon sens ça c'est oui considéré que les
gens sont des adultes et de leur dire
faites attention c'est pas évident mais
dire comme ils nous expliquent en ce
moment il faut huit jours avant noël
restez chez vous faire revenir vos
enfants de l'école pour se confiner le
jour même on décide de se déconsidérer
choisissez les gars si vous préférez
qu'on se combinent dites le nous mais
nous ne déconfit n'est pas bon de dire
autant confiné vous ça pas de sens vous
oui non mais j en fais sort gibelin vous
conseillé aux élèves de sécher les cours
je dis moi vous savez les deux derniers
jours avant je serai cross de noël
je peux vous dire que mon petit fils
m'avait déjà expliqué qu'on faisait
goûter à qu'on a apporté de quoi manger
et qu'on n'allait pas faire grand chose
sur ma 20 l es au lycée ils attendent
pas l'autorisation de ne pas y aller non
plus vous le savez très bien
donc s'ils n'y vont pas jeudi et
vendredi ça sera peut-être qu'ils feront
croire aux parents qu'ils y vont et ils
n'iront pas et comme ce sera autorisée
il y aura pas de billets et de remarques
acerbes
avant de donner la parole à nos internes
aux internautes peut-être une dernière
question la culture répression de la
culture défilé aujourd'hui dans la rue
vous avez pu le suivre en direct sur le
site du figaro est ce qu'il faut laisser
fermer
des salles de spectacles jusqu'au 7
janvier jusqu'au 20 janvier + moi
j'aurais souhaité qu'elle soit rouverte
bien évidemment un
voilà maintenant j'ai pas les éléments
quand on voit les gens aux galeries
lafayette ou au printemps on se dit bon
alors je serais très clairement on a
fait le choix des cadeaux de noël delà
de l'économie
à ce moment là il ya plus de gens qui
font des cadeaux de noël que des gens
qui vont au théâtre et au concert bon
soyons clairs là dessus
bon donc s'il fallait faire des choix en
disant pas trop de flux pas par en
rajouter on a fait le choix du commerce
on n'a pas fait le choix des concerts
des cinémas et enfin bon un peu sévère
que vous dites c'est comme si moi je
pense que je l'aurais mais je n'ai pas
tous les éléments aurions alors pas
j'aurais ouvert mais je n'ai pas tous
les éléments pour le pour le dire donc
c'est tout mais je pense qu'on a il
aurait mieux valu dire écoutez on fait
le choix des commerçants peut pas tout
faire problème c'est qu'on n'a aucune
étude qui puisse dire très précisément
d'un voilà on a une étude sérieuse qui
montre que bon à partir du moment où on
a un argument j'allais dire un peu
quantitatif suis pas scientifique jeudi
quantitative qui montre agenda nombre de
choses bon bah à ce moment là c'est plus
facile à accepter comme là on les a pas
audible pourquoi on a va avoir le droit
d'aller à la messe de minuit
pourquoi on va avoir le droit d'aller
faire des courses et pourquoi nous on ne
peut pas aller au théâtre mons a
évidemment c'est une incompréhension
après je me dis je constate que on les
musées les cinémas sont fermés aussi en
allemagne on sont fermées aux pays-bas
lors sont fermés on referme en
angleterre thomas sur le sud de
l'angleterre
donc je me dis il ya quelque chose qui
se passe voilà mais je suis pas plus
mais c'est vrai qu'on a pas d'étude la
seule étude qu'on avait c'est cette
fameuse étude américaine qui les met sur
une époque où il n'y avait pas de masque
et on ne compare est que les commerces
entre nom qu'on ne paraît pas de milieu
du travail on devrait pas loin mais on
pourrait pas les transports sont qu'on
pouvait pas dire grand chose mais pas
dire grand chose donc on finissait par
trouver que c'était les restaurants mais
bon mais bon la faute à une étude
américaine n'est toujours pas du tout
mais à défaut des jeux d'aucun du bon
sens et le bon sens montre quand même à
l'évidence qu'il n'y a pas de raison
qu'ils soient plus dangereux dans un
musée de se promener en plus dans un
musée on peut mesurer un calibre et la
jauge de façon visiteurs près puisqu'il
ya des tourniquets il suffit de fermer
le tour des questions et les musées ne
sont pas plaint pas bondés surtout qu'il
n'ya pas de chinois que les fans
américains
à l'évidence c'est pas plus dangereux
qu'un musée cagnes que qu'un grand
magasin où aucun cas une rame de tgv
plein à craquer donc pourquoi aller
faire ça pour le problème pour les
musées et les cinémas et c'est comme des
activités économiques aussi en tout cas
les cinémas et les théâtres
il ya des terres privées et même été
public donc j'avoue que je comprends pas
même le critère de l'activité économique
ne suffit pas à expliquer tout ça non je
j'avoue que moi je ne comprends pas ça
non plus voilà je dis mais si je
raisonne un peu je dis attendez ils ont
s'ils font ça c'est qu'ils doivent se
représenter ou croire qu'il y a une
bonne raison de le faire pas plus idiot
que vous et moi
donc on peut penser que le résultat d'un
raisonnement mais en tout cas c'est une
information suffisamment argumenté pour
qu'il puisse y avoir adhésion à une
personne c'est une question de rapport
au risque de relation risque qu'on
veuille bien prendre mon vieux promo
pour les autres bien sûr et pour soi
même et notices risque pénal quand on
est récente et c'est exact ce qui
évidemment je suis aura des observateurs
ça change évidemment où la dame
ils sont obsédés en vérité par le risque
pénal alors peut-être
je donne la parole à nos internautes
justement nathan nous dit chacun doit
choisir les risques qu'il doit qu'il
doit prendre y compris je pense que
nathan vous disiez ça à propos des
risques savoir s'il faut s'auto confiné
ou pas s'auto confiné nicole nous dit
après s'être autorisé à sortir il va
falloir se trouve confiné n'ont pas
mieux
jean-paul lui a dit a choisi donc l'auto
confinement nicole n'est pas d'accord
avec vous béatrice sur le conseil
scientifique la laisse la vie est
catégorique le conseil scientifique qui
a été nuls depuis le début et babineau
qu'on salue sont eux confié ce taux
confimé coûtait davino je dois vous dire
que vous êtes quand même la star de
cette émission je vais pas je peux pas
faire de jaloux
il faudra que domino viennent ici va
ouvrir et les autres les autres
internautes donc l'invitation est lancée
vous nous dites s'auto confiné de
manière préventive c'est admettre que
les tests ne sont pas fiables et le
couvre feu est une forme d'auto
confinement la proposition du conseil
scientifique est dictée par la peur est
ce que c'est votre avis bah on va
peut-être si jamais on avait une
troisième vague lire tout le monde est
sûrs leur a plus personne ne se
souviendra qu'il voulait passer noël en
famille on ira ils n'ont pas eu le
courage 2 c'est une catastrophe
voilà bon honnêtement gouverner en ce
moment c'est pas une partie de plaisir
bon voila mais comme toute façon quand
ils n'y sont pas et n'ont qu'une envie
c'est d'y être
et quand ils y sont ils n'ont qu'une
envie c'est d'y rester on va pas les
plaindre bon voilà mais oui je pense que
le le conseil scientifique qui tirait
une sonnette d'alarmé dans l'été fin
août et en septembre il avait dit un
certain nombre de choses qu'on avait
énormément mal tout sans entendre ils
composent le gouvernement d'ailleurs
donc voilà je pense que moi je comprends
qu'on puisse qu'il puisse avoir peur
quand vous voyez comment les choses
repartent de façon un peu rapide et
parfois inattendus il se dit zut quoi
bon sens si on fait pas gaffe on va se
retrouver de nouveau avec une poussée
de troisième vague en janvier donc il
essaye de je crois va de mettre des
signaux d alerte
la peur n'est pas forcément un sentiment
absurde et la logique on a davantage
il ya mille raisons dans la vie d'avoir
peur et quand tu es un enfant qui tombe
par la fenêtre
la peur et fait partie de la vie et
c'est normal que les politiques se
préoccupent de sécurité notre quotidien
la question c'est où est ce qu'on met le
curseur est métro pas trop les risques
on prend pour soi même temps pour les
autres c'est ça la vraie question
mais oui les secteurs si on prend
déprécier à une politique sanitaire
c'est bien qu'on a peur que des gens
meurent et que des gens ont peur de
mourir la question c'est juste qu'on est
on prêt à admettre qu'à son nombre de
gens meurent parce que toi son humeur
recensement 2000 sont des villes tous
les ans jusqu'aux tempes rennes m kilmer
jusqu'où à partir de quand les
précautions qu'on le prend pour qu'ils
ne meurent pas sont plus lourde de
conséquences elle le fait de laisser
moins bon ça se discute mais la peur en
soi n'est pas absolument quelque chose
de combat il faut pas que ça obscurcisse
le jugement mais la peur a un sens ben
franchement nathan 79 faudra-t-il aussi
confiné ses opinions ça c'est une autre
une autre question voyait que le doute
et qu'on n'apprécie pas son humeur on va
vous voyez qu'on apprécie votre humour
je sais pas si c'est vous qui avait
suggéré d'ailleurs un resto et un cinéma
pour babineau mais on l'a effectivement
deux raisons d'apprécier votre goût
récit il dépasse les bornes vous
inquiétez pas
sacha bekerman qui est à la modération
ce clip ras de faire le nécessaire
allons nous continuer de nous confiner
nous dit l'oit dès qu'on finira confiné
au fil des ordres et contre ordres de ce
gouvernement qui ne fait que réagir dans
la précipitation et sans anticiper les
vagues alors là du côté de la défense il
ya béatrice giblin vous dites c'est un
c'est un virus qui est assez nouveau
mais voilà je pense enfin moi je vois
les choses comme ça et je me dis que ça
il est doit être vraiment pas simple du
tout ce qui me fait dire ça un peu c'est
ce qui se passe ailleurs en europe si
vous voulez vous a pas un espèce
pardonnez-moi mais justement je pose la
question est ce que je peux le dire que
vous êtes un espèce de et c'est le
hainaut men nouveau avec ce set
ce virus l'espèce demi
sismo mondialisée à de mimétisme
mondiale ont dit à bas les autres le
font donc ça doit non justement il y en
avait qui avait pas voulu le faire et
avec des raisons je pense à la suède par
exemple qui avait dit non on choisit
tout à fait autre chose
bon apparemment ils sont en train de
revenir sur cette position qu'ils
avaient prises
donc on peut pas dire que tout le monde
était exactement dans dans un
béni-oui-oui du voisin je dirais pas je
dirais pas ça prenez l'italie par
exemple ou l'italie ont été au début
franchement il avait pris des positions
de repérer le kiosque de consignes et
tout de suite vous vous souvenez cette
petite ville à près de parme il avait eu
une politique comme celle là puis la
vague est partie extrêmement rapidement
surtout qu italie du nord et on s'était
dit bon bain avec une telle catastrophe
ils feront attention bien évidemment et
ont ils l'ont fait dans la deuxième
vague
sauf que le sud qui lui n'avait pas été
touché par la première vague c dans le
sud qu'on a eu effectivement la
catastrophe de la deuxième donc c'est
mal à se méfier parce que du jus d'ici
ont dit tout le monde et tout
confinement tout le monde quand on
regarde derrière les mots il n'y a pas
du tout les mêmes réalités
le le confinement ou tel qui a été
pratiquée dans un tronc de pin a rien
avec d'autres on est quand même le seul
tome en avoir une dans une autorisation
de sortie
toutefois d'autres pays une autorisation
pour sortir en allemagne encore
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'autres
régions vous il ya même pas de
limitations de déplacements en allemagne
il faut quand même bon en ce moment en
espagne les bars et les restaurants sont
ouverts jusqu'à 22 ou 23 heures je
croyais et les pistes de ski aussi en
italie on n'a pas le droit de se
déplacer d'une région à une autre
mais il ya un couvre-feu mais il n'y a
pas de confinement bon donc il faut
regarder et généralement des camps nous
français là où c'est le plus serré mais
à la limite si étant là où c'était le
plus dur
on avait les meilleurs résultats en
terme de mental des on peut dire bon bah
c'est le prix à payer
ce qui est un peu paradoxal c'est qu'on
ne fait partie de ceux qui ont les
mesures les depuis le début les mesures
les plus dures les plus durs en termes
de confinement et qu'on n'a pas du tout
les meilleurs
meilleurs résultats en terme de santé
publique et qu'on a les pires résultats
en termes de croissance économique et
d'un pas le faire est présente c'est ça
qui est gênant enfin le pire on se
connaît ce panier d'italie en question
sinon sur économique se sera pas
brillant non plus ce qu'on a on va
peut-être pas obligé de se noircir et
non la situation plus que plus que
nécessaire mais ce qui est sûr
révélateur dans ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'en france il n'y a pas et jamais on
n'a pas de culture de santé publique
on n'a pas de culture de prévention on a
toujours une politique curatif mais pas
très longtemps mais c'est un autre débat
je proposais on est une autre nation
parce qu'ici c'est 6 smic cela c'est un
débat passionnant j'aimerais bien qu'on
aborde l'autre question alors déjà qu'on
réponde à la question qui était posée
sur twitter est ce que vous allez vous
auto confiné et vous êtes partagés
il ya une partie d'entre vous qui le
feront et notre parti non en tout cas
pour vous être exprimé ceux qui se sont
exprimés
l'autre question vous la pose sur le
site du figaro etes-vous favorables au
référendum proposé par emmanuel macron
pour inscrire la défense de
l'environnement dans la constitution à
la question justement où la pause après
avoir entendu le chef de l'état hier
soir
l'article premier de la constitution
vous proposez de réforme
constitutionnelle la première sur le
préambule je vous ai dit pourquoi je ne
la route n'est pas en l'assumant et en
nous donnant des explications
la deuxième c'est l'article 1er elle
sera transmise en même temps que la loi
donc qui porte votre nom au conseil des
ministres ce sera une réforme
constitutionnelle en un article
constitutionnellement elle doit d'abord
passer par l'assemblée nationale puis le
sénat et être voté dans des termes
identiques
ce jour là elle sera soumise à
référendum
je veux pas spoiler mais dans les
prochaines heures zeiss tout savoir sur
les coulisses justement de cette
déclaration notamment grâce au figaro et
au service politique
voici en attendant la réaction du leader
écologiste julien bayou
une victoire c'est une victoire
culturelle majeure pour nous pour les
écologistes depuis le temps qu'on disait
qu'il faut savez on disait il faut
changer le système pas le climat est
donc évidemment il faut changer la
constitution si je ne sais pas si cette
constitue cette ce référendum verra le
jour
en fait j'y crois assez peu
quoi c'est plus en tout cas il y en a
qui n'en veut pas du tout c'est notre
confrère brice couturier très remonté
sur twitter je vous laisse lire son
tweet voyez cette convention citoyenne
aussitôt noyauté était déjà une première
erreur lui donner un pareil débouche est
une faute politique incroyable de la
part d'un homme aussi intelligent il
parle d' emmanuel macron l'électorat
écologiste ne se ralliera jamais et
l'électorat progressiste et décontenancé
et de son côté bruno retailleau qui
n'appartient donc ni à l'un ni à l'autre
dénoncent un coup de com des manuels
macron pour masquer son mauvais bilan
écologique vous le voyez cela ne
changera rien la charte de
l'environnement a déjà une valeur
constitutionnelle béatrice même eric
zemmour que j'ai interrogés ce matin
pour sa chronique hebdo en figaro
magazine et dans le figaro live le
reconnaît c'est un coup habile de la
part du président de république est ce
que c'est votre point de vue en tout cas
que sur le plan constitutionnel ça ne
change rien compte tenu de chez on
écoute un certain nombre de
constitutionnalistes qui ont pris la
parole
ils disent ça ne change rien bon à ceci
près qu'il ya toujours une symbolique
qui a on peut avoir des effets ça c'est
autre chose
bien oui le couple semblait très peu
sans peut sembler habile il faut voir
après comment les choses peuvent peuvent
tourner ça peut sembler habile dans la
mesure où
si si on a le parlement c'est-à-dire
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat qui se
mettent d'accord sur la même rédaction
ce qui n'est pas sûr l'idée par exemple
de garantie est ce que on va
si ça passe à l'assemblée il est
possible que ça passe compte tenu de la
majorité
il ya n'est moins sûr au niveau du sénat
le sénat avait déjà montré j'allais dire
plus que sa mauvaise humeur sur un
projet de loi sur cette question de
l'environnement et autres donc il aurait
pas forcément sur le changer d'avis donc
si ça arrive je vois mal très
sincèrement les écologistes appelé à
voter non d'accord d'accord donc de même
pour les progressistes donc le soutien
de management que les soutiens des
manuels macron va dire bien donc on
c'est difficile c'est là où on peut
penser que c'est habile mais on n'y est
pas encore vous a répondu à la deuxième
question avant de répondre à l'arrivée
mais en tout cas vous avez dit que
c'était plutôt habilement variés revenir
le référendum n'aura pas lieu car le
sénat est nécessaire nous dit chris
coste alors avant peut-être de débattre
de ça est-ce que d'abord de votre point
de vue alexis c'est assez habile de la
part du président ou pas moi je me méfie
toujours de ces initiatives
habile qui finissent systématiquement
par se retourner contre la ville qui les
a imaginés dès qu'on commence à jouer
avec les modes de scrutin avec les
institutions avec les référendum
on finit toujours par se prendre la
porte dans la figure enfin pas toujours
non ça serait pas davantage c'est vrai
mais souvent on se souvient le
référendum 69 d'une très bonne idée du
général de gaulle se relégitimer salaces
à la sortie la dissolution quelle bonne
idée à la dissolution en 97 ça allait
permettre à jacques chirac de leur
trouver une majorité
hop il a perdu la majorité on pourrait
multiplier comme pas mal d'exemples
comme ça les des changements de mode de
scrutin on va gagner à grâce au mode
changement de monsieur taillon perd donc
il faut toujours toujours se méfier il
ya un espèce de génie des électeurs pour
déjouer les calculs
savant là en l'occurrence alors à
prévoir ce que ces réformes se fera s'il
se faisait je suis pas du tout sûr que
macron le rend pas parce qu'il faut bien
voir les oppositions y aura toujours une
frange des écologistes purs et durs de
la gauche pure et dure qui dira ça n'est
pas assez ça ne sert à rien c'est des
mots en l'air ce qu'on voulait c'est
faire un vrai référendum pour interdire
la 5g pour isoler les bouffeurs de
l'isolation thermique pour interdire la
pub pour les autos ça c'était un vrai
référendum mais votre truc c'est bidon
donc cela ils seront pas contents toute
une frange de droite est connue libéral
de cuir présente l'historique qui est
plutôt proche de macron qui va dire mais
les entreprises ne peut ça va les mettre
dans une balade effroyable et chefs
d'entreprises du coup vont pouvoir
bah oui attendait sur la base de
garantir la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
sur cette base là ce qu'on peut pas
attaquer monsieur peugeot monsieur
renaud qui fait des véhicules thermiques
on n'en sait rien donc c'est quand même
compliqué donc ça une frange écolo qui
trouve que c'est pas bien
une franche de droite libérale qui doit
s'ouvrir et l'immense cohorte des
antilles mercredi ce qu'ils en tirent va
se le payer celui-là donc quand on joue
avec un référendum
le risque de se prendre la porte dans la
figure et grands pour cela il faudrait
qu'il ait lieu ce dont je ne suis pas
sûr mais peut-être même que le calcul de
maquereaux qu'il n'aura pas lieu c'est
ce que je pense aussi
je pense qu'il promet le référendum
parce que il a bien dit van pour que ce
soit faisable
il faut qu'on est exactement voté dans
les mêmes termes au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale
c'est ce que le référendum n'aura pas
lieu car le sénat est nécessaire ah bah
oui que le scénar et je pense que le
sénat n'en voudra pas et si jamais il ya
une autre réseau c'est à dire que c'est
connu quand il ya une question pour un
référendum c'est pas à la question qu'on
répond mais c'est pour se débarrasser de
celui qu'il la pose est bon donc là
alors la question peut-être qu'il donne
de l'eau face aux complots et 2006 à
mitterrand il s'agira qu'on a peur d'eux
a de justesse mais en vain et
franchement s'il y avait pas eu la
bretagne et l'alsace pour voter
massivement à ce référendum
ça serait pas passé 1904
exactement donc c'était pas c'était pas
gagné et si on il est avec une cote de
popularité faible au moment du
référendum et bien les gens voteront ce
qu'on reçoit bremard à ses nuits et pas
du tout pour la question quand l'enjeu
du référendum et fort les gens se bat
gascon et pour l'europe contre l'europe
c'est un vrai débat
donc on peut considérer que le débat va
l'emporter sur la personne qui met le
débat sur la table mais quand même
mais comment jouer tout faiblard sur le
point de savoir s'il faut mettre de la
constitution qui ont garanti la lutte
contre le réchauffement aura de la
licence il y aura beaucoup d'abstention
sur les gens se battront pas là dessus
parce que personne n'a envie de se
battre là dessus parce que en gros tout
le monde dit oui très bien meilleure
maintenant passons aux choses sérieuses
on est pour ou on est contre mâcon c'est
comme ça que ça va mais même dans les
débats à choses sérieuses vous pouvez
même avoir vos amis qui peuvent dire
pièces de voter non quand il pense oui
pour vous lire référendum a fait un bond
dans le référendum à faible enjeu
finalement des scouts ou monde est
d'accord finalement souvent les on n'a
pas en pleurer faire un homme de 1982
1988 sur nouvelle calédonie où le
référendum sur le quinquennat
c'était des forte abstention et ça a été
gagné par le pouvoir oui et d'ailleurs
aucune conséquence politique positif
mais pour l'auteur du roi nomme en
l'occurrence qui n'en n'a retiré aucun
bénéfice donc bon là ce qui reste quand
même c'est que moi il ya quelque chose
qui me paraît quand même énorme
c'est que toutes ses distances la
protection de l'environnement et dans la
constitution oui elle est garantie le
préambule de la constitution le peuple
français proclame solennellement son
attachement aux droits de l'homme mme
nathalie péchalat ainsi qu'aux droits et
devoirs définis dans la charte de
l'environnement et de grille ainsi la
charte de l'environnement fait adopter
par chirac déjà d'une grande
consultation fait dix articles
elle est assimilée la constitution
allait elle est entrée elle a été
assimilée au bloc de concessionnalité
par le conseil constitutionnel donc
aujourd'hui dans la constitution il ya
déjà des articles qui nous disent qu'il
faut faire en herbe le droit de 2 voire
de principe de précaution de principe de
responsabilité écologique
alors ça donne or a ajouté un de plus
qui va dire la même chose plutôt moins
bien que les 10 autres ne servent
absolument à rien donc y compris les
écoliers vont le dire ils vont dire que
ça changera pas à part que
c'était une demande et comment vous avez
4 julien bayou par exemple pardonnez-moi
mais dit que c'est une victoire
culturelle par exemple et pourtant et ce
n'est pas un écologiste tendre il fait
partie plutôt de la tendance du web
parce que c'est cette voie que c'était
une revendication mais oui mais mais ils
vont vite dire mais si vous me les voir
que d'ici deux jours et déjà je trouve
même que même jadot qui est plutôt mou
devrait commencer à dire mais est ce que
c'est ça l'essentiel
ils vont commencer à dire taux d'alcool
des sujets plus sérieux sur la table
parce que derrière cette concession du
référendum
macron de ce point de vue de mon point
de vue je pense que c'est une bonne
chose
leur a quand même renvoyé la figure la
plus part de leurs propositions les plus
dingues qui était d'interdire la 5g de
d'interdire au fond la voiture
d'interdire le l'avion de 2 x 2 les
subventions à la sncf et à tout ça il
leur a dit ouais c'est très intéressant
au fond je suis d'accord avec vous mais
on le fera pas à tous il a dit ça mais
pour les obligations en ce moment il ya
quand même quatre millions et demi qui
bouge ce n'est pas rien enfin
l'obligation ils en voulaient 22 je suis
d'accord l'obligation pour les allmand
termites
il n'est pas fou il faut pas se payer le
gilet jaune on en est ce que on a quand
même bien mais c'est surtout pas oublier
qu'on a eu on a eu un an d'émeutes dans
ce prénom pour une réforme censée être
écologique et constance tu as et les
événements les gilets jaunes
comment c'est parce que demande émanant
jaune mais pas du tout ça ne ment pas
puisqu'ils sont mobilisés contre avait
moins sûr il était donc à toute une
partie de la france périphérique
populaire rurale et périurbaine qui a
pas deux qui marche pas du tout dans ce
train et au référendum si cela vote
alors il est peu probable qu'ils aient
votre encontre ou pas ce n'est le monde
n'est pas dans mes acquis aux idéaux
écologie comme à paris ce kiosque il ira
comme vote ça moi je pense ça sera à ce
moment là que c'est toujours pareil
quand on vous demande quand on propose
un référendum c'est regarder 69 et de
gaulle quoi ce qui proposait était
peut-être une accession personnes qui
font qu'on l'avait annoncé la couleur à
l'époque en disant si vous votez non je
partais pas partir mais oui tu
m'apprends du rhin
pour l'instant durham chirac il a
compris parce que de gaulle pensez pas
qu'on dirait non ils pensaient pas donc
ça a aidé les milliers de noms et voilà
une macro le dira pas mais n'empêche que
les électeurs se dire on tient les
montrait alors il le débat en tout cas
comment un fait rage sur le tchat
jean-paul vous vous êtes 120% favorable
à la verse de lincoln on sait une
démagogie une manoeuvre électoraliste
il existe déjà la charte de
l'environnement ça ne suffit pas de
point d'interrogation et christophe est
d'accord avec vous alexis l'habileté en
politique se retourne souvent contre
ceux qui ont l'idée géniale alors ici de
la dissolution de 97 est également le
référendum du break site qui avait été à
l'étranger demandée par de cameron et
nicole encore le référendum de 2005 a
laissé un goût amer probablement que
macron ce récupérera un nom si il y a en
tous les cas chan colle un référendum
est en tous les cas et tout le monde ne
pense pas forcément comme nicole et tout
le monde ne pense pas forcément comme
nicole ça c'est un autre débat
je vous propose d'avoir ce débat au
retour après les après la trêve de noël
où il y aura il y aura une pause
également dans les émissions merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis merci
béatrice merci alexis et on se retrouve
en attendant demain avec guillaume
roquette et vous aurez gabriel cluzel et
notre consoeur de l'express claire
chartier a très vite sur figaro live
[Musique]